hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 44 hört zu und
spricht nach
perfekt gleich hilfswerk haben oder sein
plus party zib 2
mein vater
reitet auf dem pferd reiten er reitet er
ist geritten
reiten er reitet er ist geritten
er ist auf dem pferd geritten das essen
riecht gut riechen er riecht er hat
gerochen
riechen er riecht er hat gerochen
das essen hat gut gerochen
pascal schläft auf dem sofa schlafen er
schläft er hat geschlafen
schlafen ihr schläft er hat geschlafen
er hat
laufen meine mutter schließt die tür
schließen sie schließt sie hat
geschlossen
sie hat die tür geschlossen
luca schneidet die gurke
schneiden er schneidet er hat
geschnitten
er hat die gurke geschnitten ist
schreibt eine e mail
schrei
sie schreibt sie hat geschrieben
sie habe
e mail geschrieben samuel schwimmt im
hallenbad
schwimmen er schwimmt er ist geschwommen
er ist im hallen
geschwommen
meine
nachbarin sieht aus dem fenster
sehen sie sieht sie hat gesehen
sie hat aus dem fenster gesehen
andreas sitzt auf dem balkon
sitzen er sitzt er ist hat gesessen
er ist hat auf dem balkon gesessen
fabi
dein lied
singen
sie sinkt sie hat gesungen
singen sie sinkt sie hat gesungen
sie hat
mitgesungen
christoph spricht gut deutsch
sprechen
er spricht er hat gesprochen
er hat gut deutsch gesprochen
da springt in den kalten see
springen sie springt sie ist gesprungen
sie ist in den kalten see
gesprungen
oliver steht bei der post
stehen er steht er ist hat gestanden
er ist hat bei der post gestanden
christina
die treppen hochsteigen
sie steigt hoch
sie ist hoch gestiegen hochsteigen
sie ist hoch gestiegen
sie ist die treppen hoch gestiegen
der dieb stiehlt das handy
stelen er stiehlt er hat gestohlen
der dieb hat das
gestohlen meine großmutter stirbt sterbe
sie stirbt sie ist gestorben
meine groß
ist gestorben es stinkt auf der toilette
stinken es stinkt es hat gestunken
es hat auf der toilette gestunken
mein mann streitet mit dem nachbarn
streiten er streitet er hat gestritten
er hat
nachbarn gestritten meine frau
trägt einen roten pullover
tragen sie trägt sie hat getragen
trage
sie trägt sie hat getragen
sie hat einen roten pullover getragen
mein bruder trifft seine freunde
treffen
er trifft er hat getroffen
treffer
der trifft er hat getroffen
er hat seine freunde
getroffen monika trinkt ein bier
trinken sie trinkt sie hat getrunken
sie hat ein bier getrunken
jasmin verliert das spiel
berlin
sie verliert sie hat verloren
sie hat das spiel verloren
moi
versteht kein deutsch verstehen er
versteht er hat verstanden
verstehen er versteht er hat verstanden
er hat kein
meine schwester wird 18 jahre alt
werden sie wird sie ist geworden
wie
sie wird sie ist geworden
sie ist 18 jahre alt geworden
mein großvater weiß viel
wissen er war
er hat gewusst
wissen er weiß er hat gewusst
mein großvater hat viel gewusst
andrea zieht ein kleidern
anziehen
sie zieht an sie hat angezogen
sie hat
angezogen